dernier réglage retrait du dossard avant
de s'attaquer au 10 km pour les plus
endurants du parcourir Montini qui se
déroulait le 7 octobre au milieu des 350
participants Régis smot saligne pour la
4è fois à cette course son objectif
prendre du plaisir à son allure la
préparation le paris-versaill c'était
une bonne préparation après pour le
temps on verra j'espère faire aux
alentours des 50 minutes si je passe en
dessous les 50 minutes ce sera
bien Émilie triathlète de formation
s'aventure pour la première fois sur un
10 km j'aimerais bien faire moins de 45
minutes mais je sais pas du tout si je
vais l'atteindre l'objectif au départ on
va être ensemble et puis je pense qu'il
y a au moins un ou 2 km d'échauffement
entre guillemets et et puis ensuite on
va voir mais je sais pas gérer du tout
une course de 10 km donc on verra avant
le top départ l' tente est parfois
longue il ne faut pas se refroidir et
pour garder le corps à température
toutes les techniques sont bonnes sac
poubelle étirement encore petit saut sur
place avant de se rapprocher tout
doucement de la
[Musique]
ligne sur ce parcours plutôt plat très
vite Léo Didier ici en noir s'échappe
seul en tête tout juste de retour à la
compétition il franchit la ligne en 32
minutes pendant qu'au premier point de
ravitaillement c'est la course au
gobelet loin derrière lui les objectifs
de départ ne sont pas toujours atteints
mais la fierté de finir l'emporte sur la
du chrono c'est bien j'ai fait 52
minutes donc j'aurais aimé faire moins
de 50 mais au vu de mon entraînement
c'est raisonnable de faire 52 c'est dans
les temps que je fais à peu près au 10
km à ma montre j'ai vu 46 minutes donc
par rapport à mon objectif je suis un
petit tout petit peu déçu mais j'aurais
pas pu faire mieux donc au final c'est
pas grave c'était bien je me suis quand
même bien amusée je pense que je suis
partie trop vite au démarrage je me suis
emballée par le flot des coureurs et au
5e kmè je me suis ah il reste encore 5
kg
mais bon voilà je suis contente tu veux
prenne non je pour l'arriv
OK